chris rock says he's not talking about
that oscar slap oh
at least not until he gets paid
on friday the 57 year old's comedian
performed a set at fantasy springs in
indio california and for any fans who
were hoping he would weigh in on will
smith smacking him across the face at
the 2022 academy awards well better luck
next time because according to the local
paper the desert sun chris took the
stage assuring fans he's okay and life
is good adding quote i have a whole show
and i'm not talking about that until i
get paid
oh
um can someone please cut the check
because we are dying to know what chris
has to say
in the days following the incident a
source told e.t it had been an emotional
week for chris and he spoke out for the
first time since the big smackdown in
front of two sold out crowds in boston
[Music]
[Applause]
and i'm still kind of processing
what happened
fans at the show were optimistic they'd
get to hear the deets of what went down
this is a once a lifetime experience
i've always thought he was hilarious i'm
dying to know what he has to say about
what happened
with will smith chris got emotional
after he was greeted with not one but
two standing ovations
you see stars like them they seem like
they're on another level and sometimes
we feel a little detached from good
seeing that human
you know reaction and feeling that love
from boston it's like look we love you
and we appreciated you being here and
we're with you and he felt it and it
felt great
but chris when it came to the slap heard
round the world he stayed tight-lipped
[Applause]
following the incident will resign from
the academy and on friday the board of
governors wrote an open letter to
academy members revealing will is banned
from all academy events for 10 years
calling his behavior quote unacceptable
and harmful the 53-year-old king richard
starr responded to the ruling in a
statement to e.t writing quote i accept
and respect the academy's decision
of course the whole thing started after
chris made a joke about will's wife jada
pinkett smith live on air and jada she
made her first public appearance in sea
oscars on saturday at an event for
shonda rhimes flashing a peace sign for
the photographers
how are you doing good good
billy porter was also there and gave his
two cents on the altercation as a black
queer man who has been dragged through
the mud for not being masculine enough
in this world
you know
being called the cause of the
emasculation of the black man because i
decide to play with feminine silhouettes
in my clothing
it's really disheartening
that the version of masculinity shows up
like that it's upsetting
it's upsetting and i will be
the black queen
that i am
because if that is the representation of
what masculinity is supposed to be i
don't need it
[Music]